in the last video we finished off with
these two results we started off just
thinking about what it means to take the
partial derivative of a vector-valued
function and I got to these kind of you
might call them bizarre result do you
know what was the whole point in getting
here salan the whole point is so that I
can give you the tools you need to
understand what a surface integral is so
let's just think about let's draw the St
the St plane and then see how it gets
transformed into this surface R so let's
do that so let's let's say that is the T
axis and let's say that that is the s
axis and let's say that our our vector
valued function or a position vector
valued function is defined from s is
between a and B a and B I'm just picking
arbitrary boundaries and between T being
equals C and D so if we were to so the
area under question if you take any T in
any s in this rectangle right here it
will be mapped it will be mapped to part
of that surface and if you map each of
these points you will eventually get the
surface R so let me draw our in three
dimensions it's a surface in 3d so that
is our x-axis that is our y-axis and
then that is the z-axis and just as a
bit of a reminder it might look
something like this if you if we were to
this point right here where an s is
equal to a and T is equal to C remember
we're gonna draw the surface indicated
by the position vector function s R of s
and T so at this point right here when s
is a and T is C maybe it maps to I'm
just you know that point right there
when you when you take a and C and you
put it into this thing over here you're
just going to get the vector that points
at that so you could
it'll give you a position vector that'll
point right at that position right there
and then let's say that this line right
here if we were to hold s constant at a
and just vary and if we were to just
vary T from C to D maybe that looks
something like this I'm just drawing
some arbitrary contour there maybe if we
hold T constant at C and very s from A
to B maybe that'll look something like
maybe it looks something like that I
don't know I'm just trying to get an I
just show you an example so this point
right here would correspond to that
point right there when you or when you
put it into the the vector valued
function R you would get a vector that
points to that point just like that and
this point right here in purple when you
evaluate R of s and T it'll give you
it'll give you a vector that points
right there to that point over there and
we could do a couple of other points
just to get an idea of what the surface
looks like although I'm trying to keep
things as general as possible so maybe
let me do it in let's see maybe I'll do
it in this bluish color this if we hold
T at D and very s from A to B we're
going to start here this is when T is D
and s is a and when you vary it maybe
you get something like that I don't know
so this point right here would
correspond to a vector that points to
that point right there and then finally
finally this line or this if we hold a
set B and vary T between C and D we're
gonna go from that point we're gonna go
from that point to that point so it's
going to look something like this oh
we're gonna sorry we're gonna go from
this point to that point we're holding s
at be varying T from C to D maybe it
looks something like that
so our surface it's you know we went
from this nice area on this rectangular
area in the
ts plane and it gets transformed into
this wacky looking surface and we could
even draw some other things right here
let's say we have a let's say we get
some arbitrary value I'm gonna pick a
new color other than white or new non
color and let's say if we hold s at that
constant value and we vary T maybe that
will look something like this maybe that
will look something like oh I don't know
maybe it'll look something like that so
you get an idea of what this surface
might look like now given this I want to
think about what these quantities are
and then when we visualize what these
quantities are we'll be able to kind of
use these results of the last video to
do something that I think will be useful
so let's say that we pick arbitrary s
and T so this is the point this is the
point let me just put my pick it right
here let's say this is the point that is
the point s comma T s comma T if you
were to put it in if you were to put
those values in here maybe it maps to
and I want to make sure I'm consistent
with everything I've drawn maybe it maps
to this point right here maybe it maps
to that point right there so this right
here this point right here that is R of
s and T for a particular S&T I mean I
could put a little subscripts here but I
want to be general I could call this a
while I already used a and B I could
call this x and y this would be R of x
and y would map to that point right
there now so that right that's that
right there or that right there now
let's see what happens if we take if we
move just in the s direction so this is
so this is we could view that as s now
let us move forward by Delta by a
differential by super small amount of s
so this right here
let's call that a s plus a super small
differential in s that's right there so
that's that point all right let me do
that in a better color in this yellow so
that point right there
the point s plus my differential of s I
could write Delta s but I wanted this
super small change in s comma T and what
is that going to get mapped to well if
we apply these two points in R we're
gonna get something that maybe is right
over maybe is right over there
and I want to be very clear this right
here that is R of s plus d s comma T
that's what that is that's the point
when we just shift s by a super small
differential this distance here you can
view as D s it's a super small change in
s and then when we map it or transform
it or or or put that point into our
vector valued function let me copy and
paste in fact the original vector valued
function just so we have a good image of
what we're talking about this whole time
what we're talking about this whole time
let me put it right down there so when
we talk so when we took just to be clear
what's going on when we took this little
blue point right here this s and T and
we put it we put the s and T values here
we get a vector that points to that
points to that point on the surface
right there when you add a D s to your s
values you get a vector that points at
that yellow point right there at that
yellow point right there so going back
to the results we got in the last in the
last presentation or the last video what
is this R of S Plus Delta s or R of s
plus D s the differential of s T well
that's that is that right there that is
the vector that points to that position
this right here is the vector that
points to this blue position so what is
the difference of those two vectors and
this is a bit of you know this is just
basic vector math you might remember the
difference of these two vectors head to
tails the difference of these two
vectors is going to be this vector if
you subtract this vector from that
vector you're going to get that vector
right there you're going to get that
right there a vector that looks just
like that so that's what this is equal
to that vector it makes sense this blue
vector plus the orange vector this blue
vector right here plus the orange vector
is equal to this vector makes complete
sense heads to tails so that's what that
represents now let's do the same thing
in the t-direction let's do the same
thing in the t-direction I'm running out
of colors I'll have to go back to the
lab I'll go back to the pink or maybe
the magenta so if we have we had that s
and T now if we go up a little bit in
that direction let's say we go now let's
say that that is T so this is the point
s T plus a super small change in T
that's that point right there this
distance right there is DT you can view
it that way what is what if you put s
and T plus DT into our vector valued
function where you're gonna get you're
going to get a vector that maybe points
to this point right here
maybe points to maybe I'll draw it right
here maybe it points to this point right
here a vector that points right there so
that will be mapped to a vector that
points to that position right over there
now by the same argument that we did on
the s side this point or the vector that
points to that that is R of s T plus DT
that is the exact same thing as that
right there and of course this we
already saw this is the same thing is
that over there so what is that vector
minus this blue vector the magenta
vector minus the blue vector well once
again this is fairly hopefully a bit of
a review of adding vectors it's going to
be a vector that looks like this I'll do
it in white it's gonna be a vector that
looks like that this thing this thing is
going to be a vector that looks just
like that and you can imagine if you
take the blue vector plus the white
vector the blue vector plus this white
vector it's going to equal this purple
vector so it makes sense it's the purple
vector minus the blue vector is going to
be equal to this white vector so
something interesting is going on here I
these two this is a vector that is kind
of going along the going along this
parameterize surface as we changed our s
by a super small amount and then this is
a vector that is going along our surface
if we change our T by a super small
amount now you may or may not remember
this and I've done several videos where
I show this to you but the magnitude if
I take two vectors and I take their
cross product so if I take the cross
product of a and B and I take the
magnitude of the resulting vector
remember when you take the cross product
you get a third vector that is
perpendicular to both of these but if
you were just take the magnitude of that
vector that is equal to the area area of
parallelogram
I always pair powers forget how many are
parallelogram defined by a and B what do
I mean by that well if this is vector if
that is vector a and and that is vector
B that's a and that is B if you were to
just take the cross product of those two
you're going to get a third vector
you're getting a third vector that's
perpendicular to both of them and kind
of pop out of the page that would be a
cross B but the magnitude of this so
this is always going to if you just take
a cross product you're gonna get a
vector but then if you take the
magnitude of that vector
you're just saying how big is that
vector how long is that vector that's
going to be the area of the
parallelogram defined by a and B and
I've proved that in the linear algebra
videos maybe I'll prove it again in this
I mean it's because it's C mag it's it's
it's it's well I won't go into that into
detail I've done it before I don't to
make this video too long so the
parallelogram defined by a and B you
just imagine a and then you take another
kind of parallel version of a is right
over there and then another parallel
version of B is right over there so this
is the parallelogram defined by a and B
so going back to our surface example
if we were to take the cross-product of
this orange vector and this white vector
I'm gonna get the surface area I'm gonna
get the area of the parallelogram
defined by these two vectors so if I
take the parallel to that one it'll look
something like this and then a parallel
to the orange one it'll look something
like that
so if I take the cross-product of that
and that I am going to get I am going to
get the area of that parallelogram now
you might say hey this is a surface
you're taking a straight-up
parallelogram but remember these are
super small changes so you can you can
imagine a surface can be broken up into
super small changes in parallelograms or
super so into infinitely many
parallelograms and the more
parallelograms you have the better
approximation of the surface you're
going to have and this is no different
than when we first took integrals we
took we and we approximately the area of
curve with a bunch of rectangles the
more rectangles we had the better so
let's call this little change in our
surface let's call this little change in
our surface D Sigma for a little change
for a little amount of our surface and
we could even say that you know the
surface area of the surface will be the
infinite sum of all of these infinitely
small D Sigma's and there's actually a
little notation for that so surface area
surface area is equal to we could
integrate over the surface and the
notation usually is a capital Sigma that
for surface as opposed to a region or so
you're integrating over the surface and
you do a double integral because going
in two directions right the surface is
kind of a folded two-dimensional
structure and you're going to take the
infinite sum of all of the D Sigma's of
all of the D Sigma so this would be the
surface area of this so that's what a D
Sigma is now we just figure it out we
just said well that D Sigma can be
represented that value that area of that
little part of the surface of that
parallelogram can be represented as a
cross product of those two vectors so
let me write here this is all it's not
rigorous mathematics the whole point
here is to give you the intuition of
what a surface integral is all about so
we can write
we can write that D Sigma is equal to
the cross product the orange vector and
the white vector the orange vector is
this but we could also write it like
this this was the result from the last
video I'll write it in orange so the
partial the partial of R with respect to
running out of space with respect to s D
s and it's going well this thing was
going to be the the magnitude of the
cross product the cross product the
profs product by itself will just give
you a vector and that's going to be
useful when we start doing vector valued
surface integrals but just think about
it this way so this orange vector is the
same thing as that and we're gonna take
the cross product of that with this
white vector this white vector is the
same thing as that which we saw which is
the same thing as this the partial of R
with respect to T DT the partial of R
with respect to T DT and we saw if we
take the magnitude of that that's going
to be equal to that's going to be equal
to our little small change in area or
the area of this little parallelogram
over here now you may or may not
remember that if you take these so let's
just be clear this and this these are
vectors right when you take the partial
derivative of a vector-valued function
you're still getting a vector this d s
this is a number that's a number and
that's a number and you might remember
when we in the linear algebra or
whenever you first saw taking cross
products taking the cross product of
some scalar multiple you can take the
scalars out so if we take this number
and that number we essentially factor
them out of the cross product this is
going to be equal to the cross the
magnitude of the cross product of the
partial of R with respect to s crossed
with crossed with the partial of R with
respect to T and then all of that times
these two guys over here times D s and
DT so I wrote this here hey maybe our
surface area if we were to take the sum
of all of these little D Sigma's
but there's no obvious way to evaluate
that but we know that all of the D
Sigma's they're the same thing as if you
take all of the DS's and all of the DTS
if you take all of the DS's all of the
DT so this is a d s times the DT right a
D s times the DT d s times the DT is
right there if we multiply this times
the partial derivatives of the of the
cross or the cross product of the
partial derivatives this is going to
this times this is going to give us this
area so if we summed up all of this
times this or this times this if we sum
them up over this entire region we will
get all of the parallelograms in this
region we will get the surface area so
we can write I know this is all a little
bit convoluted and if you need to kind
of ponder a little bit surface integrals
at least in my head are one of the
hardest things to really visualize but
it'll all hopefully make sense so we can
say that this thing right over here the
sum of all of the little parallelograms
on our surface or the surface area is
going to be equal to instead of taking
the sum over the surface let's take the
sum of all the DS times DTS over this
region right here and of course we're
also gonna have to take this cross
product in here and we know how to do
that that's a double integral so we're
gonna take the double integral over this
we could call it this region or this
area right here that area is the same
thing as that whole area right over
there of this thing
I'll just write it in I'll just write it
in yellow of the cross product of the
partial of R with respect to s and the
partial of R with respect to T DS and DT
and so you literally just you know take
and it seems very convoluted now how
you're going to actually evaluate it but
we were able to express this thing
called a surface or well this is a very
simple surface integral in something
that we can actually calculate and in
the next few videos where I'm going to
show you examples of actually
calculating it now this right here will
only give you the surface area but what
if at every point here so over here what
we've done in
both of these expressions is we're just
figuring out the surface area of each of
these parallelograms and then adding
them all up that's what we're doing but
what if associated with each of those
little parallelograms we had some value
where that value is defined by some
third function by some third function f
of X Y Z so every parallelogram it's
super small it's around a point it's you
could kind of say it's maybe the center
of it it doesn't have to be the center
and maybe the center of it is some point
in three-dimensional space and if you
use some other function f f of XY and Z
you'll get the value of that point and
we want to do is figure out what happens
what happens if for every one of those
parallelograms we were to multiply it
times the value of the function at that
point so we could write it this way so
this is where you can imagine the
function is just one we're just
multiplying each of the parallelograms
by one but we could imagine we're
multiplying each of the little
parallelograms by f of x y and z d sigma
and it's going to be the exact same
thing where this is each of the little
parallelogram so we're just going to
multiply it by f of XY and z there so
we're going to integrate it over the
area over that region of f of x y and z
and then times the magnitude of the
partial of R with respect to s crossed
with the partial of R with respect to T
D s DT and of course we're integrating
with respect to s and T hopefully we can
express this function in terms of s and
T and we should be able to because we
have a parametrizations air wherever we
see an X there it's really X as a
function of s and T Y is a function of s
and T Z is a function of s and T and
this might look super convoluted and
hard and and the visualizations for this
of why you'd want to do this it has
applications in physics it's a little
hard to visualize it's easier just to
visualize this straight up the straight
up surface area what we're gonna see in
the next few videos that it's a little
hairy to calculate these problems but
they're not too hard to do that you just
kind of have to stick with them